the jurgen experience and
here's a good testament to how if you
see past the [ __ ]
of what divides us and labeling people
this and that
you can always because we had a lot
jason flom and i
you know who's a board member at the
innocence project we were overwhelmed by
the outreach
just from being on your show and talking
to people how can i help
one thing you can do to help is always
keep an open mind with regardless of who
you're dealing with that's an easy way
to help
watch this i represent the chairman of
marvel entertainment his name is ike
perlmutter
billionaire many times over he's happens
to be
closest friends with donald trump way
before he was president
i could have used that as a way to
separate myself from him
to dismiss him and i represented him
i still do in this wild case where his
dna was stolen and he was accused of
something he didn't do
and ike perlmutter at one point said
you're not paying enough attention to my
case
and it was because i was working on an
exoneration case in florida
clementi's case actually and he he
started following the case in the press
and this isn't a guy that was like some
criminal justice reform advocate he said
it struck him that if i didn't have you
and roy black who's a famous criminal
defense lawyer that was handling this
civil case if i didn't have
you and the resources to fight this i
would have been accused
of a crime i didn't commit and it struck
him
that he had the resources to make a
difference so he started making
gifts in my honor to the innocence
project substantial gifts
and i could have everybody around me
said you're friends with this guy you've
become
friends with him and he got enlightened
to the point where in december
i'm in florida a week before the capitol
riot
he called me and said josh look i want
to help get somebody executive clemency
if i can
and i want you to figure out one person
that you think is
you know the most um deserving candidate
for it and let's try to get it before
the president i was in florida he was in
florida
he said you're going to meet with the
president
and look a lot of people would have said
to me [ __ ] crazy how could you meet
with him
i don't care about any of that i'm
trying to save a life
so there's a a retired judge federal
judge named john gleason who started
this project called the holloway project
where his he he started to realize
exactly what you were talking about
people on non-violent drug offenses
where there were just disproportionate
sentences he had a list of people where
you know to come up with one was
difficult but i asked him
barry scheck who's the one of the
founders of the innocence project
and various others who do you think is
if you had to give me a list of 10.
so i got lists and judge gleason's
client was this guy named jawad musa
who was in baltimore
the worst possible circumstances he gets
arrested on this reverse dry sting they
call it
where he's asked to cobble together
twenty thousand dollars
and make a heroin purchase in new york
and no drugs ever existed it was all a
scheme it was a set up by an informant
he cobbles together five of the twenty
thousand dollars
goes to new york gets arrested on the
spot
and sentenced to life in prison jesus so
i read about him
he's in jail for over 30 years oh jesus
he has he has 52 degrees
certificates
by all accounts judge gleason said look
he pointed out areas in the law
that i had never considered so i i could
not get this guy off my mind
so i finally put him forward as the
person
so i i thought that i would submit
paperwork
and it would go away so one week before
the capitol riots
ike called me and said you're going to
come to dinner tonight
with your wife and you're going to
present the case to various people in
the white house
at mar-a-lago now there are some
democrats
left-leaning or otherwise you're going
to go to mar-a-lago and i would always
say
hell yes i'm going there i'm going to
try to save someone's life
i met with ivanka trump
jared kushner and just explained to them
the case
and i got to tell you she said look i
really admire your work at the innocence
project
um i think this is really noble we we
think that this is a
a great candidate for executive clemency
and it was like throughout the dinner it
was on to the next person
on to the next person so at one point
there's a table like we're sitting at a
table
and literally the distance you and i are
from each other there's two
empty seats and it dawns on me that
we're going to be having dinner with the
president and his wife
so at some point he walks out and
everybody stands at mar-a-lago and claps
when he comes out
like kim jong-un what's worse than that
i think
you've ever seen kim jong-un oh yeah
i've seen the most famous i saw the
videos of it yeah you see the recent one
no the recent one is mind-blowing
he walks in but oh we'll get to that in
a minute all right so so
i said to ike do i have to stand and
clap and he goes if you want your pardon
you do
so i stood and clapped so dinner
is progressing and we're not talking and
fine you know we're not talking about
this so finally ike says to me look
he wants to talk to you about this case
now and he asked me a bunch of very
pointed questions
so all of a sudden then i find myself at
a table my wife
myself the president the first lady
ike perlmutter and his wife and he says
look i hear i hear great things about
you from mike tell me about the case
tremendous tremendous things i mean it
was
so [ __ ] loony i remember him saying
i want ice cream ice cream two scoops i
want two scoops two scoops he kept
saying i don't know why that stuck with
me
but he said he told me this story he
said you know do you uh
do you think he's innocent i said no i
don't think he's innocent
executive clemency we're asking you to
pardon him
it was a non-violent drug offense i
explained the whole case to him and he
said i can't i had jim brown come to me
the famous running back
and the guy was a murderer i couldn't do
that i only want non-violent drug
offenses
and he said where is he going to work
when he gets out and i said i've offered
him a job
he has this paralegal certificate that
he got in jail
and he said you'll employ him i'll
employ him
a week later so i meet with him he tells
me
call white house counsel and then a week
later the [ __ ] capital riot happens
so everybody involved in this potential
presidential pardon cycle this is a wrap
this isn't happening
the last day of his presidency
the last day i was at ike's apartment
with my wife and kids and the phone rang
and he goes it's the white house
he said don't go anywhere because we
were walking out and he walked out and
he said
the pardon was just signed and the
i don't know this man i never met him my
immediate
release of them i started to weep openly
um you know it there's just no
feeling that you can ever put into words
when you help restore another human
being in that way
now jawad musa and i met for the first
time over
facetime you know four days later
i flew his brother to meet him he was in
colorado
some awful facility in colorado
i flew his brother out there he got out
like that
the pardon happens and then you're out
he was flown back to baltimore we met in
the airport
on face time and we were immediately
felt like
bonded like brothers he now works for me
and his insights in the five months
four or five months that he's been out
his insights on cases
a man that's been 30 some odd years
working on it became like a
jail lawyer you realize that there are
people
human beings that have been forgotten
that have so much potential
if someone just cares so now he's you
know
it's not without problems he's working
on getting his official
out of jail paralegal certificate but
you realize that if you just
create connections and and allow i don't
want to sound like some
silly infomercial but i easily could
have found reasons why
not to try to enlighten someone whose
politics were different than mine
and ike promoter was the least likely
person but he's now
i've found that if i if you tap into it
and and turn his mind on to the human
suffering
he now wants to start a criminal justice
reform center that we're working on
together
so i just feel like sometimes in a world
where our politics are so divided it was
one of the more bizarre
meals i've ever had two scoops
two scoops but it was worth it man
wow catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now to
get this full episode
of the joe rogan experience